my name is angelica mullins
and i work with chevron
and i came with a team of people uh from
our innovation services team
and they are the ones who encouraged me
to come to this to this program
i've actually sat in today's session and
really thought about
how to you know apply what we've
been hearing you know over today and
yesterday
and um i like the two
phrases uh to uh attention
and intention i like how that was
defined
for us because a lot of times we intend
to do things but we don't actually give
it the attention
that it needs in order to get it done
and so
if i were to think about that that's the
one thing that i am taking back with me
is uh intent that when i intend to do
something i really
am going to put the attention needed to
get it done
try it do it actually because i
came with a you know a preconceived
idea of what i thought it was going to
be like you know that it would be
somewhat intimidating and maybe over my
head
and but i actually found that that
everyone
was like me just wanting to change our
our thinking styles perhaps and just to
do better to take chances
and you know to drop the fear
that we have and just go for it
i've there's so many things i really
can't put a name to that i've
learned but really after going back over
my nose
and re-playing what's been said today or
you know over the course i'm certain
there's so much more
to take back with me to not just for
work but even for my personal life and
so
i'd say do it that's if i had this you
know put it succinctly just do it
it's great i mean you're not gonna walk
away not learning anything
you're gonna take away something